there all right ashley thank you for
that some pretty great
nfl games coming up this weekend ron
petrel joining us now to talk about some
of the betting angles for the teams that
are still
in the postseason okay so there are
eight teams left in the nfl playoffs
right now there's two games on saturday
two games on sunday
first the saturday games the bills and
the ravens play in the evening
the earlier game is going to be the rams
and the packers interesting matchup here
so far all the small bets are going with
the packers right now
the big money the so-called wise guys or
sharps they're taking the rams
public is still on the packers actually
the the money is about equal right now
that
uh but that public money and we've
written five times as many tickets
on the packers as we have the rams but
you know the rams were able to
control uh contain russell wilson and dk
metcalf so
we'll see if they can do it again at
green bay with the packers here and
aaron rodgers
an interesting point here with casino
betting down tremendously right now
because of fears over coronavirus
sports betting is actually breaking
records
people coming to town they're not going
to go out and spend 500 at the club and
200 on a show so they've got some extra
money this is the only entertainment so
they throw it down on the sports uh
events and
we've seen that in the record number of
handles we've had the last three
uh months and then you have the sunday
matchups cleveland takes on kansas city
in the early game here on channel eight
by the way the raiders beat both of
those teams this year then you have that
great quarterback matchup
brady takes on brees as the bucks travel
to new orleans against the saints
i'm ron fucher reporting eight sports